vinson play for the Brooklyn Dodgers and
getting arrested at the civil rights
demonstration are two pivotal moments in
the life of journalist Jack newfield his
new memoir somebody's gotta tell it
details these and other experiences
throughout his 40 years as a
self-proclaimed working-class journalist
at the Village Voice New York Daily News
and New York Post this talk from the
politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC is 45 minutes good evening
everyone and welcome to politics and
prose on behalf of the owners of
historic Barbara meat and Carla Colin
and all the staff were glad to see you
here we welcome you and we're glad also
to see you here to welcome the author
visiting with us tonight jack new field
who will be talking about his new memoir
somebody's got to tell it many of you
are probably familiar with his work in
journalism his books and his
emmy-winning Emmy winning documentary
those of you aren't I think you'll
really enjoy hearing him talk tonight
and read his book the format for tonight
is that he'll be talking to you taking
questions and then when you come up when
you have a question if you would come up
to the mic here in the center aisle it
would be a big help because for one
thing c-span is here tonight so the
questions can be heard but even for your
fellow audience members it would be a
help and mr. Newfield will not have to
repeat the question um and then after
that he'll have some time to sign mr.
Newfield is known as a journalist who
has a strong sense of self of social
justice and he's a person who can be
said to have integrity in that he did
not separate his career and his work
from his values he's seen some of the
most amazing thing things happen in this
country over the past few decades and in
his book he talks about
some of those and some of the people
involved so with no more words on my
part please help me welcome Jack new
field thank you all for coming thank I
want to thank politics and prose for
inviting me what I've decided to do is
to read two excerpts from my book the
first one is the first Brooklyn Dodger
baseball game I have a sore and the
second one is the first time I got
arrested and there's a connection
between the two
on july 4th 1948 i got to see my first
baseball game at Ebbets Field the father
of a friend took three of us to see the
Dodgers play the crosstown rival Giants
we sat in the bleacher seats and ate
hotdogs and peanuts my memory of that
spectacular day is bittersweet I missed
not having a father of my own to do this
with the thoughtful kindness of my
friends dad somehow made me more aware
of the hole at the center of my own
existence the fleeting feeling of loss
came back to me when I started taking my
own daughter Rebecca to Mets games in
the 1980s renewing the American ritual I
never got to perform with my own father
I remember crying in the darkened movie
theater when Rebecca and I saw a field
of dreams together and the dead father
and the living son were playing catch
unscrew on the screen walking out of the
runway into the sunlight of ebbets field
and that long ago July fourth I felt
like I was entering a cathedral the
colors were so sharp the green of the
grass the white of the Dodger uniforms
the reddish brown of the earth the
yellows and blues of the shirts and the
crowd I still get this goose bumpy
feeling whenever I walk into a ballpark
and I'm sure there was some kind of
subliminal flashback to the first sight
of rowdy intimate colorful epid field
for all the hours aids spent listening
to the games on radio I was not prepared
for the carnival atmosphere the Dodgers
symphony with the trumpet drum and
cowbell parading around the pack stands
or the camaraderie of the fans The
Passion of the routing those commingled
pungent aroma of mustard cotton candy
peanuts and cheap cigars
most of all I was not prepared for the
level of sound 34,000 human throats
could manufacture with the proper
incitement and in this first baseball
game I ever saw jackie robinson stole
home these days nobody steals home it's
a lost art Jackie would do it 19 times
in his career and once again in the
nineteen fifty-five World Series one
thing you couldn't really tell from
listening to the radio was how fast
Jackie Robinson could run you had to see
the power in his football stride and the
abandoned in his eyes he was a tornado
with a temper in September I got to see
a second game we waited for some fans to
leave after the first game of a
doubleheader and they gave us that
ticket stubs so we can sit in their
seats for the second game a lot of kids
did this and it usually worked on this
occasion we ended up sitting behind
first base and kept moving down closer
to the field as people left later in the
game we played cat-and-mouse with the
ushers until we were close to the
playing field by the ninth inning what I
remember about the second game was
Robinson getting hit by a pitch the
whole ballpark food with fury because by
then all the Brooklyn New jackie was a
marked man by pitchers who resented his
existence during his rookie season
jackie was hit by pitchers nine times
which is still the record and in those
days batas did not wear protective
helmets there was another reason I
identified with Robinson I read in the
New York Post that Hank Greenberg had
supported and befriended him all my
relatives said Greenberg was the best
Jewish role model in America he was the
vicarious vessel for Jewish immigrant
dreams the Jew as athlete who made all
Jews feel more American and more Jewish
even my mother talked about Hank
Greenberg as a god my Jewish uncles told
me the Greenberg
broken babe ruth's record of 60 home
runs in 19 38 but anti-semitic pitches
starting pitching around them and
walking him when he reached 58 this was
believed by most of the Jewish grown-ups
I knew but later when I looked it up I
can see the Greenberg struck out a lot
the last week of the season including on
the last day when Bob Feller struck him
out twice he had his chances but it was
true that Greenberg was the victim of
anti-jewish slurs and several
intentional spikings during his career
and in 1947 when Robinson came up and
Green Bay and greenberg was playing out
his final season with the Pirates he did
go out of his way to encourage Robinson
Robinson appreciated the friendship he
later wrote and talked about the
importance of Hank Greenberg's
encouragement to him the kinship between
Blacks and Jews would play a big role in
my life and this alliance between
Robinson and greenberg was probably my
first awareness of this kinship of
hardship the other passage I want to
read describes a demonstration in not
far from here at a place called gwynn
oak amusement park right near Baltimore
also set Angela under July fourth early
on the morning of july 4th 1963 four
busloads of new york activists set out
for baltimore at about 11am we arrived
at the metropolitan methodist church it
was packed with 400 singing inspired
people Oh was music important to the
movement to my surprise there were short
speeches by a parade of clergy the
protest was much more religious based
than I realized students were the
soldiers not the generals here first
Eugene Carson Blake the leader of the
United Presbyterian
Church spoke emphasizing non-violence
and the need for direct action and the
obligations of religious leaders to join
the civil rights movement then Monsignor
austin-healey of Baltimore's Catholic
Archdiocese followed by several black
ministers and a rabbi and the local core
chairman ed chance also blessed and
baptized us for battle when we arrived
in discipline fashion at the appointed
place of arrest we were surrounded by
about 300 hostile mostly teenage
hecklers some waving Confederate flags
some shouting out insults like jungle
bunny and [ __ ] lover and most
memorably stick them all into baltimore
zoo this was not Manhattan the Eastern
Shore of Maryland was a hotbed of racism
George Wallace would do very well in
these precincts in the presidential
campaigns of 1964 in 1968 the face of
white resistance was shouting white
[ __ ] and spitting saliva at me there
were plenty of adults and clergy in the
group waiting to get arrested the
proportion of dark suits and clerical
collars struck me as much as the white
hostility on the hillside some of the
demonstrators went limp compelling
Baltimore County police to carry them on
a very hot day to the waiting police
vans a few hundred yards away I walked
to the van singing the star-spangled
banner since it was July 4th there were
a lot of TV cameras to record this first
mass arrests in Baltimore most of those
arrested were white and this pleased a
chance of core and the local black
ministers they feared the protest would
be smaller and blacker we were all
charged with trespassing on private
property once in the van I saw many
folks I knew it was a reunion there was
todd gitlin the president of SDS and
mickey schwerner of core who would be
murdered in mississippi 11 months later
there was Lee Webb and Richie Rustin of
SDS and Teresa del pavo of snick and
there was Danny kalbe the guitarist with
the Blues project when I got to a
holding cell I met Julian Beck and
Judith Molina the founders of the Living
Theater were aware I had seen Jack
Gilbert's play the connection about jazz
and heroin later I would learn that
among the 283 people arrested that day
was John Darton than a student at
Wisconsin and now a top editor at The
New York Times sometime that night in
the Baltimore jail I made the connection
that I was that it was exactly 15 years
earlier on july 4th 1948 that I saw my
first baseball game and saw Jackie
Robinson steal home Jackie Robinson had
led me to this place of protest it was
July 4th and I felt just as proudly
American in a police van as I had an
epic sealed eating a hotdog and keeping
score baseball and nonviolent civil
disobedience seemed equally consistent
with patriotism and citizenship I had
sung the star-spangled banner getting
arrested and before my first Dodgers
game who could know that within seven
years it would all turn to lunacy the
whites getting evicted from snick dr.
King and Mickey Schwerner getting
murdered SDS turning into vandals and
bomb makers Tom Hayden glorifying the
gangsterism of ue Newton and the Black
Panthers Stokely Carmichael shouting the
poison of Zionism equals racism Jerry
Rubin calling siahaan sahan a freedom
fighter sts leader bernardine dohrn
praising Charles Manson and three days
after this all happened my friend Ralph
Featherstone of snick would die when his
cut when a car carrying a bomb went off
when I was released when the Baltimore
jail the next morning I rushed to find a
copy of the New York Times how would
they play our mass witness to
segregation on private property in the
North they put it on the front page
early in the evening of August
twenty-eighth I was riding in a car
filled with SDS and snick friends
returning to New York from the vast
march on Washington we had just heard
dr. King's I have a dream speech and Bob
Dylan we were in a state of grace King
had been a combination of Scripture
Lincoln and Shakespeare that hot and
humid afternoon the immense integrated
perfectly behaved multitude was a sight
and a thrill I will never forget it was
a community suddenly somebody in the car
said I got an idea let's go back to
Gwynn Oak and get arrested let's sit in
our into our integrated group arrived
about 7pm just as a cooling breeze was
starting to break the oppressive heat of
the day but instead of facing arrest our
group was informed Gwen Oaks Park had
been desegregated for the first time
that very day our group was welcome to
pay Rodman our admission fee the
historic day ended with me and my
friends going on the rides at the top of
the ferris wheel I sang the old
spiritual Oh freedom at the top of my
lungs Oh freedom over me and before I'll
be a slave I'll be buried in my grave
and go home to my Lord and be free thank
you any questions
get things started Jack I love your
phrase the the kinship of hardship and
I'd like you to apply if you could about
the challenges then versus the challenge
is now in forming a kinship of hardship
in this very specifically between blacks
and jews or blacks and jews or yeah and
you can reach beyond that if you choose
in America kinship of hardship in
America well I think we had that in the
first half of the 60s to me the civil
rights movement from the Montgomery bus
boycott to the voting rights act of 65
was the the peak of that kind of
community and coalition it began to fall
apart after 65 and when Robbie Kennedy
and Martin King were murdered in the
spring of 68 I think that aborted what I
thought was going to be the natural
culmination of all the struggle of that
decade which would have been Robert
Kennedy's presidency and Martin King
leading a mass movement to make sure he
did the right thing and we lost both of
them I said I said I in terms of blacks
and jews jesse jackson went said
something very helpful to me at a panel
discussion about black-jewish relations
and he said the problem with
black-jewish relations is that it's like
a plant that the blacks and jews put in
the garden put in the earth and every 20
minutes they rip it out of the soil and
she has a grown yet no oh what's the
problem and in terms of the children of
Jackie Robinson and the children of hank
greenberg i think the solution is just
collaboration and work on things we
agree on and and work at the grass roots
in support of a common agenda and don't
pull the plant out of the earth every 20
minutes and
see if it grew yet I think it will grow
through collaboration to common
struggles through common objectives
around poverty racism all the things for
people and intellectuals of conscience
and agree on but i think i would like to
believe that ideas are the engines of
history but my experience has shown me
that you also need leaders you also need
visionaries to connect with a movement
and you need both i think now the goal
is to recreate a movement without the
great leaders that we had that have long
gone one of the great people I've ever
known the fannie lou hamer who i still
call mrs. Hamer because she was so so
awed by her used to say we are the
people we're waiting for don't wait for
a leader you start working today
whatever you can and whatever small
scale you can on your block in your
neighborhood in your city it's almost a
political equivalent of the line of
field of dreams build it and they will
come
mr. Newfield I was one of the white
Jewish snake people who was gently or
not so gently told to leave I know what
some of the arguments were among the
non-white snake leadership why do you
think it happened and do you think it
there was anything positive to that step
which hurt us so much I I've talked to
people about this ever since late 64 I
think it was I think it was a mistake
politically and historically but I think
a lot of my friends and snick was so
injured psychologically and emotionally
by the lynching of goodman chaney and
schwerner and by what happened at the
1964 Democratic convention where I think
that the Democratic Party was at fault
for being so patronizing to the
Mississippi freedom Democratic Party and
only offering to symbolic seats and
being willing to seat a segregated
racist delegation picked by eastland and
Stennis and and telling us that we're
going to get in return is the savior of
you but Humphreys vice president so shut
up and don't protest this and take your
two seats and get back on the bus and go
back to rural Mississippi so I think the
great liberal democrats of that a year
including Mondale and Humphrey made a
big moral political blunder in in doing
that and that I think helps set into
motion the events that I witnessed it to
Waveland Mississippi later that year
where the leadership of snake came to I
think mistaken conclusion to have to not
have the tastes to have a black movement
try to create a multiracial society and
I think you need a multiracial movement
to create a multiracial society it was I
thought it was a terrible mistake and as
i remember john lewis was sort of eased
out of the snick leadership in a coup
and oust why I remember Stokely and rap
Brown than taking over and I think
things went in in a tragic direction
after that I think the the urban riots
and Watson in 65 and then in newark in
detroit in 67 led some very smart people
to think america was in a revolutionary
situation i remember being in newark
with tom hayden and andy capp kind and
they're telling me the revolution is
starting and I said what do you mean
they're robbing a liquor store I don't
understand and I think that was a
turning point but I've always felt that
if the 64 Democratic convention had not
said no the way they did mrs. Hamer and
Bob Moses things good at history might
have gone in a different direction
I met fannie lou hamer once or twice
when I was an undergraduate school I
never forgot the experience do you get
the impression that Martin Luther King
was about to to convince poor middle
class whites that they were being used
also did you ever get the impression
that that was a possibility yes I think
you know certainly he was in the midst
of his Poor People's Campaign when he
was murdered he was trying to unify poor
whites from from Appalachia in uptown
and Chicago with Mexican Americans with
Indians with everybody I think he his
vision was that was his vision I saw him
speak and then had dinner with him three
weeks before he was assassinated when he
spoke it for the hospital workers union
in Manhattan to mobilize support for the
Poor People's Campaign has said of his
biblical text that night that night was
Michael Harrington's book the other
America and that was his vision and he
was also I think coming close to working
at an understanding with Malcolm X 24
King to to remain in when Malcolm was
killed in 65 to divide the country north
and south Malcolm had come to Selma and
he admit what Andrew Young and that
alliance was potentially coming together
well they would agree to disagree about
non-violence as a tactic but there was
going to be a meeting I know but
probably about two weeks after Malcolm
was killed with that kenneth clark and
the Clarence Jones and Andrew Young were
putting together for what King and
Malcolm to work things out and I think
King had a phenomenal understanding of
the role of labor in in social justice
and he had an alliance we do with unions
and he died helping the Sanitation Union
in Memphis
public employee union so I think what
was in Kings mind the night he was
assassinated is the starting point for
American politics as far as I'm
concerned over a multiracial movement of
the poor to change the country through
direct action and through non-violence
and through an alliance with labor I
don't know of a better and to grassroots
organizing hadn't over better agenda
Jack on a completely different subject I
had the advantage of reading the book
which I love you talk a lot especially
in the last part of the book about media
and about newspapers and their ownership
and and some things that happen to you
which doesn't it's not a very pretty
story about management and I wonder if
you could reflect a little it's it's
obviously based on your experience on
what happened at the daily news on the
new york post and maybe in a little bit
at the Village Voice but what that all
tells us about the implications of media
ownership for freedom of expression and
for all of us getting information we
need in a free society that's a very
important question I found myself
involved in mutinies of one sort or
another at all three papers I work for I
worked for The Village Voice for 24
years and in Saudi in 1971 we try to
form a union and we didn't finally win
it until nineteen seventy-seven but
ownership resisted you know the most
modest kind of unionization knows that
the Daily News in 1990 I was a
management employee and the chicago
tribune company owned the news and they
decided to break all 10 unions at the
paper the they provoked a strike I was
in a tough position since I was
management and I agreed the two of the
unions were run by gangsters particular
joined the late John Gotti but I decided
to quit my job and support the strike
and work on a picket line because I felt
union-busting and hiring scabs was
immoral and that even unions that bat
220 have a right to live but that was I
learned what distant corporate power
because since the Daily News was owned
by the Chicago Tribune and they were
based in Chicago and there were
ruthless bean counters deciding to get
more profit out of the daily news the
news had a nine hundred thousand readers
at that point but they and was making a
lot of money but they wanted to break
the Union so they can make more money
and then my most recent encounter with
the corporate journalism when I was a
columnist on the New York Post owned by
Rupert Murdoch and Murdock son took over
running the paper and I had been a
columnist for ten years without a
contract and one day the new editor call
me it was office and and there were five
people in line behind me who were about
to get fired and I got fired and just
said you're we're moving in a new
direction here's your severance package
we hope you sign it and then I saw some
of my closest friends coming into the
room right after me and it turned out to
be five Jews in a black woman who was
dying of cancer at the time and we were
all fired so I have a sense of how
brutal and irrational and concentrated
corporate power in the media is and I
got another taste of that a few months
ago when I was assigned to write an
article for New York magazine about the
impact of the road trade center atrocity
on poor people in low-wage workers and I
spent two months in finding five poor
people to profile and write about and
then when i submitted the article they
decided well we'll pay you what we're
not going to run it it's a downer for
our advertisers we really shouldn't have
assigned it to you nobody wants to read
about the unemployed Ecuadorian
immigrants who were here illegally so I
think there's been a trend in the media
for the last 20 years probably towards
you know celebrities and gossip and
the most trivia kinda trivial conception
of what news is and it's harder and
harder except for the very best paper's
like the the times in a Washington Post
and The Wall Street Journal to to do
serious reporting particularly about
issues of poverty or race or corporate
corruption until it reaches the level of
Enron John Gotti death got more coverage
in New York than than anything else the
last last week and he was just a dumb
gangster but the media is going in a
direction of a meaningless fame and
trivial gossip rather than in-depth
reporting and or long-term investigative
projects so I think that there is a the
concentrated ownership plus the
influence of in some of this tabloid
television journalism is just assuming
that the younger generations have a
shorter and shorter attention span it
was a demographic and marketing theories
that anyone under 30 who grew up with
the gizmo and MTV which I call the gizmo
generation that they have they what they
can only absorb information and in
30-second bites or nothing longer than a
Britney Spears video
and you were notes more generally about
how your sense of social justice
guided you through different situations
and issues because it's not as simple as
it sounds well the first two chapters of
my memoir I think try to explain how
much I was originally shaped by growing
up in bedford-stuyvesant section of
Brooklyn as it was becoming a
predominantly black neighborhood and my
going to boys high which was a
predominantly black high school and what
a wonderful enriching experience that
turned out to me foot turned out to be
for me foot my falling in love with red
rock and roll and and the blues and jazz
in the 50s integrated my mind before the
supreme court decision desegregating
schools when you're 15 and 16 and your
heroes are Jackie Wilson and Chuck Berry
or Jackie Robinson and Sugar Ray
Robinson or a little later miles davis
and john coltrane your pre-programmed to
join the civil rights movement when i
say in the book that the BB King and ben
e king with a warm-up acts of Martin
King for my generation at least because
before the supreme court decision record
stores and baseball box scores were
integrating my mind and the biggest
effect of all is what i read implied was
jackie robinson the experience of being
nine ten eleven year old dodger fan in
brooklyn as jackie robinson was
integrating baseball was proving in 9
inning installments that the myth of
white supremacy in baseball was a myth
and then you know how what a threat he
was to the establishment of baseball
it's probably to America and what he
went through and how much he suffered
and to see him get spite and being
and while being handcuffed and told you
cannot retaliate you cannot strike back
I date a lot of my concept of social
justice to to Jackie Robinson because he
taught me that inclusion is better than
exclusion and if you give everyone a
fair shot the hole gets better the
Brooklyn Dodgers were in second place in
1946 and they went a pendant in 1947 and
it was clear to a ten-year-old like me
that Jackie Robinson was the difference
between success and failure and I think
I people tend to take when Robinson went
through and accomplished for granted
these days but I think he I consider his
first game in Brooklyn the beginning of
the second half of the 20th century I
think if he had hit 180 and been sent
back down to Montreal and didn't make it
the history would have been pushed back
10 or 15 years they might have pushed
back the Montgomery bus boycott the
marches for integrated schools when the
first times I came to Washington was to
see dr. King speak here in the april of
nineteen fifty-nine when King was only
29 years old and it was an astonishing
experience too familiar at 21 to hear
this twenty-nine-year-old minister from
Montgomery but I think it all goes back
to Jackie Robinson
is my sister-in-law it might be a trick
question yeah yeah I'm halfway through
this wonderful book and I'm taking the
metro back and forth so i can keep
reading it instead of driving my car it
really is a wonderful book and it's not
because he's my brother-in-law that's
supposed to be why criticising Jack you
have portions in this book where you
really talked about what kinds of
journalistic dispositions you have that
in the end the way you do your work and
it's very instructive because you know
when you connect it to the your own
analysis of the media these days it
seems to me useful for us to hear
exactly how it is you put your stories
together because they're quite
remarkable and they keep on coming and I
think they also address the question of
justice are and how you sustain this or
this investigative brilliance that you
have so could you talk about that a
little bit what you do to make a great
story well I I try to deal with the
individual particular injustice rather
than global theory i learned po some of
that from from michael harrington when
he wrote the the other america it was
reportage about poverty Michael was a
democratic socialist the word social has
never appeared in that book he wanted to
get people's attention for a problem and
he dramatized it through description and
which was what John Steinbeck could do
or jacob riis with his journalism and
photography in the 1890s so I think one
kind of method methodological previs is
the particular second is to pick a cause
or an issue and stick to it don't write
one or two articles and move on to the
next subject the things I've done that
I'm most proud of written about for at
least two years consecutively
continuously in 1969 I began
to write about the problem of lead
poisoning in slum children and must have
written 25 articles over a two-year
period when John Lindsay was mayor of
New York because I was writing to have
an effect any politician any bureaucracy
can laugh off one or two articles but
when they know there's going to be 30
and that eventually television is going
to pick it up they begin to become
responsive and eventually Lindsay as
mayor appropriated a lot of money to
screen slum children for lead poisoning
and to fix up apartments where poisoned
children were found and eventually the
Congress Ted Kennedy in the congressman
from Manhattan named bill Ryan drafted
and passed a bill creating federal
funding to combat lead poisoning but
unfortunately Richard Nixon impounded
the money which is one of the thousand
reasons I hit Richard Nixon to this day
and I was once speaking at Columbia
Journalism school and I was asked by a
student who is your role model as a
journalist is it is that I have stolen
who I had talked a lot about in my
remarks or is it Jacob Riis and try to
be facetious I said my role models a
journalist is Joe Frazier what I was
trying to say was determination
relentlessness repetition aggression
never stopping I mean very sure the
students I think understood the metaphor
I was trying to create but there is an
element of what Joe Frazier did that I
try to apply to journalism and being
relentless and the another long crusade
of relentless follow ups involved a
young man named Bobby McLaughlin who was
convicted of murder in Brooklyn and was
in the sixth year of his 25 to life
sentence
when his foster father in a homicide
detective came to see me with all the
evidence from the case and the phone
numbers of the jurors and transcripts I
spent about three months reading
everything I went to visit Ravi and
greenhaven prison and became convinced
he was innocent and then we spent you
know year and a half writing about it I
got TV journalists involved like John
Miller and I got dick schaap to do a
piece on a the ABC network and after two
years a judge found that Bobby
McLaughlin who was innocent had been
wrongfully convicted and was released
from prison but it takes a couple years
of this kind of constant relentless
angry follow-ups to move a system
particularly a system like the criminal
justice system that is reluctant to
admit error and you just have to shame
people and at the same time being
activists go on radio shows go on TV
shows be a lobbyist which is what Jacob
Reese would do in lincoln steffans would
do to be an agitator and an organizer as
well as a muckraker Sarah did you know
our Lowenstein and what was your
impression of our Lowenstein oh boy I
knew I Lowenstein very well there's a
lot in my memoir about him I had
probably as it as mixed feelings about
al as i had about anyone I've ever known
he was he did so much good in Africa in
Mississippi in organizing the campaign
to dislodge Lyndon Johnson from the
presidency and 68 he started in the
spring of 67 and went around the country
organizing little groups of people
of students and professors and teachers
and even conservative students to go
against Johnson and he made people feel
less alone in their own resistance to
the war but he also did some awful stuff
he read baited my closest friends in the
civil rights movement like Bob Moses we
didn't speak for years about what he did
there he attacked the people who are
running the Vietnam moratorium in 69
because he couldn't control it the way I
think he couldn't control what Moses was
doing in the grass roots of Mississippi
with people like like mrs. Hamer I think
al al was a liberal who kept putting
himself in revolutionary situations and
he stayed a liberal and each and he was
a little bit of a control freak
particularly in Mississippi but I think
and it so I had no good and bad
experiences with him but I think his
loan campaign to begin a movement to to
drive Lyndon Johnson out of office over
the Vietnam War was one of the heroic
things in American history
okay I'm trying to figure out how to ask
you a question about contemporary
politics and you're you're here
promoting a memoir which is about
history so let me try it this way you
and Paul de Brule Road this very
insightful book about the that came out
of the fiscal crisis in New York City
the the first one of several it was the
abuse of power republish as the
permanent government which was the title
we originally wanted I see and and and
as I remembered you were very strongly
regretful that what had been created in
New York the high standard of public
goods in that era the Nixon era and the
ER that we were living in was being
stripped away and we don't have free
tuition higher education anymore we
don't have all those things that once
New York was emblematic of and that you
talked about the process in which they
were lost yet today you're here I think
still committed to the view of how to
create a majority that we had in the
early 60s absolutely and given the
distance that we've come how remote that
is how hard it would be to imagine
getting back to that but not getting
back to it is something to advocate but
getting back to it is something that
worked and worked as a majority politics
they have any misgivings about being
miss your ad politically I misgivings
about where I'm at yeah but he doubts
about care about what whether that view
of how to create a majority that we had
in the early 60s is still the one that
we ought to be advocating I think that
what dr. King and Robert Kennedy were
trying to do in 68 is as I said before
my model of how to get to a majority
Mike Harrington used to say we'd have to
aim for the frontier of the possible and
to locate that frontier and then fight
for it I don't know anything anyway I
think we've had a
a lot of defeats since the election of
Richard Nixon and a lot of things have
gone in a different direction in New
York City but my views have become
probably a lot more nuanced and
complicated as you grow older but I will
i still think the the speeches at RFK
gave in 68 in and the speeches I saw a
king given 59 in 63 and 65 and Selma and
67 at Riverside Church about the Vietnam
War are the new constitution that's
where we should go back to what's my if
I had a political slogan it would be
back to the future
thank you thank you very much please and
now mr. Newfield will sign some books
the line will form over here on the left
here and if you would help help us all
have room to walk and line up you could
fold your chair and leaning against
something stationary thanks very much
for coming out today and hearing mr.
Newfield jack new field has been a
columnist for The Village Voice New York
Daily News and New York Post his books
include the education of Jack new field
only in America Robert Kennedy his
latest is somebody's got to tell it the
upbeat memoir of a working-class
journalist it's published by st.
Martin's Press online at st. Martin's
calm